I had a middle-class and that's
typically the people who have come to
the US and are very grateful you
mentioned that you still have relatives
there do you are you able to call them
on the phone yeah we part we talk with
them on the phone it's you never know
who's listening of course but it is
possible
our guest is Umberto Phan Tova his book
is Fidel Hollywood's favorite tyrant
thank you for your time thank you thank
you and we're gonna go across the street
to Chapman auditorium for our final live
event today this is a panel on science
and inventors the guests are Alan
Lightman
Rebecca Goldstein and David Levithan for
being with us this weekend at the Miami
Book Fair International
it's just an audience who likes writers
no I'm want to say I want to begin by
seconding Barbara we have all had a
great festival here it's this is
tremendous fun for all of us who leave
our chilly and dismal climbs to come
here to Miami and I know Dave berry is
gonna be a tough act to follow precede
us in this instant if any of you heard
the Rock Bottom Remainders last night
amazing rock band to hear Scott Turow
sing mustang sally' is really something
you don't want to miss and I also want
to thank Mitch Kaplan for putting
together just an incredibly vivid
vibrant festival balancing to joy to
come down here finally since I'm going
on with such enthusiasm I'm also
grateful to be here in my fledgling role
as a publisher I started a company three
years ago and one of the ideas we had
was to produce a series of books which
we call great discoveries that would
link great writers with scientific
subjects and this panel coheres
we have rebecca goldstein the author of
incompleteness on the life of the
mathematician kurt gödel and david
levitt the author of the man who knew
too much about alan turing we have Alan
Lightman the professor of physics at MIT
who's now turned professor of writing at
MIT
whose book is this year is the
discoveries
great breakthroughs in 20th century
science the origins of the series which
we produce in collaboration with WW
Norton was to give a sense that science
was accessible to the lay reader and I
thought of CP snows famous description
of the two cultures humanities and
science that were so remote from each
other and so unable to communicate their
knowledge this is something that I was
particularly aware of as a person in the
humanities with a math SAT that will
remain a blot on my entire life
solo and I wanted to be able to to cross
this divide myself when we started out
we weren't sure if it could actually be
done but to my amazement it turned out
that there were a large number of very
well-known writers who were adept
sufficiently adept at science to be able
to write cogent accessible vivid
narratives about science we began with
David Foster Wallace a book called on
infinity
everything you want to know and more and
that was an accurate description no I'm
the publisher that was not accurate
description and Barbara Goldsmith on
Marie Curie Madison smart Belle and with
wasnae it was very exciting to see these
writers bring such a depth of knowledge
to science David they are all three
novelists all three of our panelists are
novelists of distinction Rebecca is a
professor of philosophy and has been
writing novels I remember very vividly
her first novel the
body mind body problem about a young
woman becoming aware of her sexuality
young Orthodox woman at college I
remember vividly David's arrival on the
scene also about 20 years ago it's his
first stories about family life and
Ellen also became a novelist after
establishing himself as a very
distinguished physicist I'll just go
through the template here of their
achievements which are numerous as you
can imagine among Rebecca's other novels
as properties of light and if I may brag
for a moment then completeness was
called an enthralling intellectual
biography in The New Yorker and compared
to Davis o bells longitude she's also a
member of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences a MacArthur Fellow and a
recipient of the whiting award David is
the author of the novels the lost
language of cranes equal affections the
page-turner and most recently the body
of Jonah Boyd and he just told me a few
minutes ago that he's also started a
literary magazine and has become an
entrepreneur and was talking to me more
about distribution that Ingram's then
about his new book that's very
impressive what's the name of your of
your magazine subtropics and he's a
recipient of fellowships from both the
Guggenheim Foundation and the National
Endowment for the Arts family dancing
his first collection published when he
was just 23 was a finalist for both the
National Book Critics Circle Award and
the pen/faulkner award and the reason
his magazine is called subtropics is
because he teaches creative writing at
the University of Florida in Gainesville
Allen is the author of four novels
Einstein's dreams good veneto the
diagnosis and most recently reunion and
numerous books on science including
ancient lights great ideas and physics
for the stars and the book I mentioned
just out now the discoveries as I was
thinking about these three panelists and
what they have in common I was struck by
the fact that we often think of novels
as a novelist has engaged in some
otherworldly occupation writing dark
stories about dark figures which I
suppose is true enough and yet the
precision in these books their ability
to deal with mathematical concepts and
physics and scientific concepts which
they seem to have worked up and learned
and mastered not in an informal way very
impressive to me but I also had an
insight into the resemblance between the
lives they write about and the lives of
novelists that is to say and they will
tell you about this that the life of a
Vale and touring the life of girdle
whereas tragic in their own way as the
lives of the novelists that we read
about and I think this congruence is
really fascinating something I hadn't
thought of before so I'm going to turn
the proceedings over to them and Alan
will talk first for about 20 minutes
followed by Rebecca and then David and
then we will have some discussion and
take questions from the audience so
thank you very much and welcome our
panelists
thank you Jim for that wonderful
introduction and it's great for me to be
here I love Miami and I thank all of you
for coming in one of the most remarkable
narratives of scientific discovery the
German biologist otto Livy recalled how
the idea came to him for testing the way
that nerves communicate and the idea
arrived in a dream and I want to read
you Levy's account of this dream the
night before Easter Sunday of 1921 I
awoke turned on the light and jotted
down a few notes on a slip of paper then
I fell asleep again it occurred to me of
six o'clock in the morning that during
the night I had written down something
most important but I was unable to
decipher the scroll haven't we all had
that experience the next night at 3:00
a.m. the idea returned it was the design
of an experiment to determine whether or
not the apotheosis of chemical
transmission from one nerve to the next
was true I got up immediately went to
the laboratory and performed a simple
experiment on a frog heart according to
the nocturnal design well Einstein had
his thought experiments and Ernest
Rutherford had his damn fool ideas but
very few scientists have had their great
ideas and a dream about five years ago I
decided that I want to explore the
nature of discovery in silence in the
20th century now that it's 2005 we can
just start to grapple with a whole
century of scientific thought and I want
to know how scientific discoveries
happen
what is the mind of the scientist
how many discoveries are accidental
versus intentional or the scientists
aware of the significance of their work
at the time are there common patterns of
discovery is there a common creative
process in science
how do styles of working and thinking
vary from one science to the next and
from one scientist to the next how do
the personalities of scientists compare
so I began badgering all of my friends
at MIT and elsewhere my colleagues in
astronomy physics chemistry biology and
asking them to nominate for me the
greatest discoveries in their field in
the 20th century and I got about a
hundred nominations and I decided I
wanted to collect the original papers
because I think when you have the
original paper you can you can really
hear the voice of the scientists
speaking and so I collected these papers
and some of them were hard to get some
of them had been published in obscure
journals some of them required
translation into English and I gathered
them together here was the original
discovery of special relativity here was
the discovery of how the form of the
first hormone another communication
system for the body here was the
discovery of the expansion of the
universe here was the discovery of the
nucleus of the atom here was the
discovery of the structure of DNA and so
on I felt that these papers themselves
were extremely important there's a
mythology in science that the original
papers don't matter that it's only the
bottom line that matters and I think
that that mythology is wrong so I felt
that I had gathered together the great
novels and symphonies of science and I
went out down this
list of a hundred nominations - about
two dozen papers and two dozen
discoveries and in my book I tell the
human story of each of these two dozen
discoveries and try to compare the
process and one against the process of
another and then I give the reader a
guided tour through each of these
original discovery papers I don't love E
and the discovery of how nerves
communicate was one of my case studies
and in 1921 at the time of his dream it
was known that nerves form the principal
communication system of the body what
was not known it was also known that
that a signal goes to do down an
individual nerve in the form of
electricity what was not known was how
one nerve transmits its signal to
another nerve or to an organ in other
words how to nurse talk to the rest of
the body the leading theory for that was
that that that process was also
electrical that each nerve generated a
little electrical current which flowed
to the next nerve levees
middle-of-the-night
experiment was was not only simple but
it was elegant and what he did was he
took the hearts out of two frogs he kept
the these hearts alive and beating by
putting them in a fluid and he removed
all the nerves from the second heart he
then inserted a little metal tube into
each heart and filled it with a chemical
called ringers solution which which
keeps an isolated organ alive he he then
stimulated the vagus nerve of the first
heart now the vagus nerve is a nerve
that slows down any organ and he found
just as expected that the beating of
that heart slowed down after he
stimulated the vagus nerve he then took
the solution that was in the first the
chemical that was in the first heart and
poured it into the tube leading into the
second nerveless heart and it also began
slowing down
then he did the same with the
accelerator nerve of the first heart
stimulated it an accelerator nerve made
a beat quicker and quicker and then he
poured the solution from the first heart
and the second and it also began beating
more more quickly and this demonstrated
without a doubt that there's some
chemical that a stimulated nerve
transmits to an organ to make it to
communicate its signal this was the
beginning of the science of
neurotransmitters such as adrenaline and
acetylcholine and it has had enormous
impact on brain science well I wanted to
describe and a little more to tell one
of my favorite discoveries in the book
and this was a discovery by a very
little-known woman astronomer named
Henrietta Leavitt how many people have
heard of Henrietta Leavitt not many
yes
yes Jim Jim's company just recently
pulled published the first and only book
about Henrietta Leavitt well Henrietta
Leavitt left it very little behind
she wrote just a small number of letters
to the director of the Harvard College
Observatory where she worked during her
lifetime she received no medals no
honors no honorary degrees there are
just a few sentences about her and most
astronomy books and the problem that she
worked on was how to determine distance
in space but she didn't know that that
was the problem she was working on at
the time
let me just backtrack for one minute and
say that a major problem in astronomy
has always been how do you determine the
distance to the stars because when you
look up into space you just see like a
2-dimensional photograph you can't tell
how far away those little points of
light are if stars all came in the same
luminosity or wattage then you would be
able to tell while the brighter winds
are closer and the dimmer winds are
further away but in fact stars come in a
range of wattages and there's no
reference plane so you can't tell how
way the four stars are and without
knowing how far away they are you don't
know anything about the universe you
don't know how big our galaxy is you
don't know whether there are other
galaxies beyond our galaxy you don't
know really anything about the universe
distance is key and what Leavitt did is
she found a way for computing the
intrinsic luminosity the wattage of a
particular group of stars variable stars
that pulse on and off unlike our Sun and
change and brightness getting dimmer and
brighter and dimmer and brighter and she
found that there was a relationship
between how the cycle time of one of
these variables
and its intrinsic wattage and once you
know such a relationship then you can
find one of these variable stars
somewhere else in the cosmos you can
measure a cycle time you can look up on
her chart and therefore get its wattage
and then from knowing its wattage you
know how far away it is just as you can
tell how far a 50 watt bulb is by how
bright that appears or 75 little watt
bulb so she found a way of measuring the
true wattages of stars and therefore
giving astronomy its third dimension her
discovery was was used to measure the
size of the galaxy which is about a
hundred thousand light-years in diameter
and a light year is the distance that
light travels in one year going at
186,000 miles per second our Sun is
about seven light minutes away it takes
about seven minutes for a light to get
from our Sun to earth the nearest stars
about five light-years away and the
galaxies our galaxy the Milky Way said
about a hundred thousand light years
away and using Levitz way to measure
distance an astronomer measured the size
of our galaxy another astronomer in 1924
measured that there are other galaxies
outside of our galaxy and in 1929 yet a
third astronomer well actually were the
same astronomers the second one and when
Hubble measured that our Y was able to
conclude that our universe is expanding
that it that all the galaxies are moving
away from each other and there was a
beginning and time about 15 billion
years ago called the Big Bang which has
enormous in meaning for not only science
but theology philosophy and all of this
was possible because of henrietta Levitz
work she was born in 1868 in
Massachusetts the daughter of a very
religious father and she remained
religious her entire life she never
married she was called messed miss
Leavitt her
life and in 1895 she became a an
assistant at the Harvard College
Observatory where she worked with a
bunch of other women in analyzing stars
on photographic plates photography was
just coming into use and astronomy
around 1900 and suddenly you had a huge
amount of data that you had to analyze
because each photographic plate could
record the positions and brightnesses of
maybe a thousand stars and so you you
you needed cheap labor for all of this
and of course where do you find cheap
labor in 1900 you find it with women
this was actually one of the few jobs
and science that women could get and
these women around 1900 were paid 30
cents an hour which translates a day
into about $8 an hour they were called
computers these women were called
computers another thing about Henrietta
Leavitt story that I love is she
eventually became deaf and so she worked
in this world of silence analyzing these
photographic plates of distant stars and
distant space in this world of silence I
love that image her title the entire
time that she worked for Edward C
Pickering at the Harvard College
Observatory was just assistant and she
never wanted anything more than that a
few astronomers during her lifetime knew
of the importance of her work which she
received no honors as I as I mentioned
and she died young at age 52 of cancer
before her death she left all of her
possessions to her mother and I wanted
to read to you a list of the possessions
that she left to her mother bookcase in
books $5 folding screen $1.00 rug for
$40 table $5 chair $2 desk $5 bedstead
$15
two mattresses $10 one bond at $100 face
value one bond at $48 and 56 cents in
1925 three years after she had been dead
as a member of the Swedish Academy of
Sciences which Awards the Nobel Prize
wrote a letter to her saying that he
would like to nominate her for the Nobel
Prize from my sample of two dozen
discoveries I have created sort of a
taxonomy of scientific discovery which
I've just published in the magazine new
scientists and of course it's it's risky
business to try to categorize anything
dealing with the creative process
because we don't really know exactly
what goes on in the mind during creation
but I have attempted such a
classification and I wanted to read you
a few of the categories they're about a
half a dozen categories of discovery and
all first there is the accident in which
the scientist discovers something that
he or she was not looking for Henrietta
Levitz discovery was an example of that
another was was Alexander Fleming's
discovery of penicillin there is a rare
category which I call principles first
used by Einstein in which the scientist
begins with some sweeping philosophical
principle about the universe really a
way that the scientist wants the
universe to work and then derives the
consequences of that postulate and
Einsteins work on relativity theory
followed that that pattern where he
started with a postulate about saying
that there was no absolute motion
absolute rest in the universe there's no
such thing as absolute rest you can only
tell motion relative to another another
object there is the timely clue in which
the scientists was receives a vital clue
just at the right moment in time after
they've been working very hard on a
known problem Barbara McClintock
discovery that genes can move around on
chromosomes was an example of getting a
very good clue just at the right time
Franklin Roth and Franklin Jim Francis
n't and Frances and Crick I'm sorry
Watson and Crick and Franklin also got a
very good clue just at the right time in
their discovery the structure of DNA
there's a discovery by analogy when you
use a previous scientific discovery to
to make you think of the right pattern
for a new discovery a Hans Krebs who
discovered the citric acid cycle was
used this this method this is a cyclic
whence of biochemical reactions that
breaks food down into energy and it
follows a cyclic pattern where each
chemical is regenerated and you you keep
going around a loop regenerating the
chemicals that came before he had
discovered a previous cycle in
biochemistry and was thinking in terms
of cycles many other scientists were
working on this problem but krebs was
the only one who was thinking in terms
of cyclic processes and so he was able
to discover the missing steps to make
this sequence of reactions a cycle there
is a discovery when new tools become
available that one Hubble who discovered
the expansion of the universe had edited
as disposable and as exclusive disposal
the largest telescope in the world the
hundred inch telescope on Mount Wilson
other astronomers were working on the
same problem but none of them had this
this exquisite new tool and finally
there's something I called the long hall
in which an astronomer just I mean that
astronomer but a scientist just works on
a problem very hard over a long period
of time and finally cracks it and max
Brutus discovery of the structure of the
hemoglobin molecule was an example of
this there is a common pattern that I
found in many of the discoveries from
the 20th century and
the pattern is something like this first
you do hard work and you have prepared
mind I don't know of any examples of
great discoveries in the 20th century
and silence even the ones that were
accidental in which in which discovery
was made by an untrained amateur the
prepared mind is extremely important
next you get stuck getting stuck is a
very important part of the creative
process somehow it seems to stimulate or
catalyze the imagination getting stuck
is a good thing not a bad thing and when
we get stuck on problems we should just
be patient and know that it that's
stimulating our creative imagination
then there's a shift in thinking or
perspective and finally the discovery
and I think that this pattern of
discovery is universal to the creative
process I've seen it happen with
novelists with actors with musicians it
seems to be a very common pattern and
many but not all creative discoveries I
wanted to end with just a couple of
comments about the scientific
personality I think most non scientists
feel that have a pretty good idea about
what a scientist looks like and and and
what a scientist is like a stereotype
and those of us who are either
scientists or have science friends know
that that's really not true that there's
actually a wide range of scientific
personalities some scientists are bold
and brash and revolutionary like
Einstein or Watson or Rutherford other
scientists are modest shy even quiet
like Krebs or Lisa Meitner of the
nuclear physicists or Henrietta Leavitt
who I mentioned William Bayliss who
discovered the first hormone in 1902 was
a man who was very cautious when he did
science he was careful
he loved the details the fine print and
yet his collaborator earnest Starling
was brisk and patient didn't have any
patience for the details just like the
broad suite of things but what all of
these men and women share despite the
differences in personality is a passion
to know a sheer pleasure in solving
problems and an independence of mind
when the American Bible biologist
Barbara McClintock when she looked back
on her career later in life she recalled
that in high school science classes
quote I would solve some of the problems
in ways that weren't the answers the
instructor expected it was a tremendous
joy the whole process of finding that
answer just pure joy and when Lisa
Meitner of the nuclear physicist who
discovered nuclear fish nuclear fission
when she was a little girl her
grandmother told her that she should not
so on the Sabbath because it was bad
luck and the heavens would come tumbling
down so the little girl decided to do an
experiment at age at age six
she took her sewing needle touched it to
her fabric just touched it waiting a
minute
looked up
nothing happened then she took a single
stitch she waited looked up nothing
happened and finally she was satisfied
that her grandmother had been mistaken
and she went happily about her sewing
thank you
hi it's a great pleasure to be here and
I I do just want to say one word
thanking Jim Atlas for his great vision
in in seeing the the narrative the drama
the passion in in science and and making
this serious happen when I was I thought
that I would tell you how it was that I
chose Kurt gödel as my as the subject of
my book when when I first heard about
the project and when I was first
approached to contribute to it it didn't
take me very long to to hit on Kurt
gödel as as the man that I would want to
write about and they were basically
three reasons that that girdle was the
man that I that I chose first of all as
Jim had mentioned in his introduction I
am a novelist but I'm also a professor
of philosophy and I was trained in
philosophy I got my doctorate in
philosophy actually never had any
intention of writing a novel until I
wrote one I'm the only novelists I've
ever met who never had cherished this
dream of becoming a novelist but just
had a novel in her and wrote it and then
wrote a few more but but I think of
myself professionally as a philosopher
and the interesting thing about Kurt
girdle's work his very famous result
which is called the incompleteness
theorem they're actually two related
incompleteness theorems and I'll tell
you a little bit about what they say in
a moment but one of the very fascinating
things about it is that this is a
mathematical result with all of the
precision of mathematics which with our
proof that's what we get in mathematics
and a beautiful proof by the way when
that's on it's and it's its general
structure quite easy to grasp the
details are
more complicated but this is a
mathematical proof with all the rigor
and and precision of mathematics that
has something philosophical to tell us
it's important philosophically Kurt
Godel himself considered himself more a
philosopher than a mathematician he was
only interested in doing mathematics
that had some sort of light to shed on
on philosophical issues mathematics is
is very puzzling to us as philosophers
because it's our one area of knowledge
where we can get certainty there's
there's not that wonderful story about
Lisa Meitner and the sowing that she she
she had a theory here and her and she
when she did a little experiment and it
wasn't it was falsified her
grandmother's theory was falsified and
she could throw it away interestingly
enough in mathematics experiments
falsifiability are irrelevant
we have proofs in mathematics once
something is proved it's proved and it's
in immune to provision we philosophers
call this a priori it's it's it's
somehow it's the the proof of it is not
at all dependent on experience its prior
to experience it's immune from empirical
falsifiability how do the likes of us we
offspring of random processes of
evolution how do we come by certainty
how do we have this kind of knowledge
that is immune from revision that it's
just it's just thinking and we can prove
things it's very very mysterious and one
of the great mysteries is whether or not
mathematicians like scientists are
actually discovering something whether
they're discovering an aspect of reality
or maybe a meta reality a reality beyond
spatio-temporal reality that that
they're uncovering in their proofs or
are we simply constructing systems and
and inferring the consequences is is
mathematics a higher form of chess you
make up your rules and then you see what
follows these are some of the questions
that we ask about mathematics they're
not really mathematical questions
they're meta mathematical they're about
mathematics the incured girdle had very
strong views about what the nature of
mathematics was he believed that it was
discovery that one was actually
unveiling one was actually discovering
an external objective mathematical
reality in once proofs we call this
Platon as a mathematical Platonism and
Goethe was a very very strong plainness
it's it's inch people disagree very much
over the philosophical implications of
girdles theorems but they were motivated
by girdle himself in trying to
understand something of a philosophical
nature so as a philosopher this is
mathematics this is that is extremely
important and very very interesting it's
an interface between mathematics and and
philosophy also girdles theorems even as
well what are they maybe I should just
state them first of all they're there to
the first thing the first incompleteness
theorem says that in any formal system
that is powerful enough rich enough to
express arithmetic there will be a
proposition which is stainable within
that system which is true but can't be
proved in that system so the system is
incomplete it can never capture all of
the true mathematical propositions not
even an arithmetic which is the most
elementary and simple as the foundation
of all of all other higher mathematics
so there's this incompleteness this two
girdles Clayton aspyn had seemed exactly
right that our systems is not are not
creating these mathematical truths that
they're discovering them but the
mathematical truths are true independent
of the systems and the second
incompleteness theorem is that one of
the things that
can't prove within a system is the
system's own consistency this is known
as the second incompleteness theorem
this is very devastating because an
inconsistent system is completely
worthless you can prove anything in an
inconsistent system because from a from
a contradiction everything follows so an
inconsistent system is worthless and
while you're working in a system you
can't tell you can prove within that
system that it's consistent you have to
go to a higher system in order to go
back to prove the first systems
consistency but then how do you know
that higher system is because you know
you get a kind of infinite regress it's
not very comfortable it's not it's a
little it's incomplete and so this is
this is fascinating but what it actually
tells us philosophically you know it's
debated we know what gertle thought it
told but but there's there's a lot of
debate about this but it's certainly a
philosophical interest it's
philosophically rich so that was very
very interesting to me also another
philosophical problem that has some
relevance perhaps to girdle's
incompleteness theorem is the nature of
the mind if mathematical knowledge is
somewhat mysterious it casts a little
mystery on the nature of the human mind
as well which has this that this
mathematical knowledge even while Goethe
was still alive in 1962 a philosopher
named John Lucas had published an essay
saying trying to use girdle's
incompleteness theorems to show that the
mind can't be a computer that that we
have mathematical knowledge that would
exceed any programming and that this was
the implication of girdles and
completeness theorems quite recently
Roger Penrose wrote to mega selling
books the emperor's new mind and shadows
of the mind trying to argue exactly this
that our minds are not
digital computers and that the basis of
of the argument is girdles and
completeness theorems so there's there's
something of real philosophical
substance here in in girdles
incompleteness theorems and so it's very
it was quite interesting to meet girdles
incompleteness theorems here's the sort
of segue into the second point that made
me very interested in girdle they're
often there he's not as famous as his
very good friend Albert Einstein they
were very good friends they had a
legendary famous friendship in in in
Princeton and he's so his incompleteness
theorems are not as famous as Einstein's
relativity theories special in general
nor Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
but these three major ideas of the early
20th century girdles and completeness
theorem Einsteins uncertainty principle
and I'm sorry Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle have I been saying
Einstein the whole time Heisenberg's
uncertainty principle and Einstein's
relativity are often linked together as
part of a postmodern attack on the
notions of objectivity and rationality
that even in the hard science Sciences
there's relativism there's you know from
relativity there's uncertainty from
Heisenberg there's incompleteness from
good ol but it goes along with a general
skepticism about objective knowledge and
rationalism in in general it was very
very interesting me to me expect
probably the primary interest that I had
in writing this book that at least two
of these three Einstein and girl
who had this famous very actually
mysterious friendship because they were
very different in their personalities as
Alan said scientists don't have always
the same personalities and this was
these were very different men but they
had this very very fast relationship
that these two quite the contrary
did not believe that the implications of
their very famous results discoveries
was the rejection of objectivity and
rationality but the quite the contrary
they interpreted their own discoveries
as affirming the notion of objectivity
Goodall in in mathematics and Einstein
in in relativity this was part of
Einstein's argument with with with
quantum mechanics or with a certain
interpretation of quantum mechanics so
it's but if I as I was I often would
hear girdle's incompleteness theorems
sort of generally vaguely associated
with you know we can't know anything
nothing is certain
nothing is objective we make it all up
and it was ironic and paradoxical that
this he set out to prove exactly the
opposite and that's how he interpreted
his his mathematical results the other
reason I was so interested in girdle is
the man himself the personality the
paradox not only of that lies in the
heart of the the implications that have
been drawn the paradox that he actually
assimilates
into the proof itself but the paradox of
girdle himself he was a an interesting
man
he was quite neurotic and he was it
actually intensified and dark it
darkened into true paranoia he died a
very tragic death he believed that he
was being poisoned and he stopped eating
and so he starved to death
so this was the man who was he was at
the Institute for Advanced Study when I
was a student at Princeton he was
universally in our very small little
world that is designated as Aristotle
successor the greatest logician since
Aristotle and he was the victim of such
a logic in the in the in the more
general popular sense of the word and
and such irrationality interestingly it
was a kind of rationality run amok he
believed in effort there was a reason
for everything everything was
intelligible
one of the sayings that he had I found
it in with his knock loss his literary
remains there in the library of
Firestone library and Princeton was
developed as their new dick the world is
intelligible at its rational and the
irony and the paradox and the tragedy of
this man who was able to see and go
where people know one had really gone
before he turned actually logic into a
mathematically respectable field his his
work had all sorts of interesting
mathematical implications and beyond
mathematics into metamathematics into
the philosophy of mine it's
extraordinary work of a logical sort and
and and yet he was when it came to life
quite helpless quite clue clue is quite
maddening as a matter of fact and this
kind of character has always fascinated
me in fact in my fiction many of my of
my books have dealt with characters who
have this extraordinary genius this
ability to go where no man or woman has
gone before to be able to see with such
lucidity and yet who just bumble through
through life and and are often you know
quite unhappy themselves and may
certainly make people around them often
quite unhappy off and there's
and so in my first novel my about a
problem there was a you know a
mathematical genius and in my last novel
properties of life there were three
physicists who were of this sort this
this extraordinary vision coupled with
with tragic unseeing and when I actually
think back I had met girdle when I was a
graduate student and I was quite a party
at the Institute and there was just a
very brief window when he was gregarious
he was a great recluse after his one
good friend Einstein died he really
didn't speak to anybody else and I
interviewed people at the Institute who
who had known him no he was completely
isolated he made people quite annoyed
with his his determination to always
look for reasons and for everything and
he was his is his insistence on all
sorts of procedural requirements he
tried to he tried so hard to be logical
that he was vastly illogical and he made
his colleagues quite upset and they
actually had very little to do with him
he wasn't truly isolated but for one
very brief period there was a period
when he was gregarious for about two
weeks and he happened to be I came to a
party and I was there and and then I
read in one of the journals by Oskar
Morgenstern another person who had been
at the Institute that recounts how der
Adel surprised everybody showed up at
this party and he was holding court
among a group of admiring young
logicians and mathematicians and and I
was one of them and all of us of course
were were way too intimidated by the
appearance of the God to ask anything
questions and there right there was one
question in particular I had wished I
had asked him what he thought about this
argument and had just that had been
published in 1962 trying to argue that
can't be computers based on his own work
anyway I thought I would just read a
little bit this is this is after I do
all all the work of of the of the proof
which as I say it's a very very
beautiful proof this is the other thing
is that one can get a sense of what it
is what that mathematicians mean when
they talk about the beauty and the
elegance of proofs if you haven't
experience this for yourself it can
sound quite odd but but mathematicians
are the aesthetics is very very
important to them they have a deeply
developed sense of beauty and this this
proof is it's a beauty it's and it's
quite accessible very few symbols are
required and this little section that
I'm going to read is called pink
flamingo there it was inconceivably Kay
girdle listed just like any other name
in the bright orange Princeton community
phonebook it was a sweetly surreal
moment I had just arrived as a graduate
student at Princeton and just for the
thrilling improbability of it had looked
up the name of a towns most dazzling
mind the reigning if reclusive God at
the fabled Institute for Advanced Study
a bucolic 3-minute stroll from where I
was living it seemed almost axiomatic to
me in those days that the greatest
mathematical mind which happened at that
moment in history to be identical with
Kurt girdles mind was necessarily
identical with the greatest of all minds
Kay girdle it was like opening up the
local phonebook and finding be Spinoza
or I Newton the Princeton community
phonebook had offered me the
unbelievable largesse not only of a
telephone number but also the street
address the girdle of course once I had
this information there was nothing else
for me to do but to hop on my bike and
pedal my way over to see the house on
145 Linden Lane it was a simple wooden
affair orthogonal Eve situated in
relation to the street unlike all the
other forward-facing houses and this
singular
seems somehow just right the
neighborhood certainly wasn't
Princeton's choices
it was a hot September day and the
streets were treeless and the street was
treeless depressingly exposed to the
high noon Sun there wasn't a soul
stirring around the girdle house but the
visit did manage to deliver yet another
surreal wallop the sliver of a front
yard was completely dominated by one of
those pink plastic flamingos that stands
poised on one skinny leg I stared in
disbelief at the bird how could a man
who had produced one of the most
exquisite masterpieces of human thought
have planted a pink flamingo on his
front lawn of course there was a mrs.
girdle a former cabaret dancer by
popular report she used to say she was a
ballet dancer but she wasn't visions of
Dubois angle danced through my head and
I hastily attributed the lawn ornament
to a Marlena Dietrich type turned on
likely New Jersey hausfrau I was hardly
the only Princeton Dennison who was
fascinated with the elusive celebrity of
pure thought in our midst
I once found the philosopher Richard
Rorty very prominent philosopher
standing in a bit of a daze in
Davidson's food market he told me in
hushed tones that he'd just seen girdle
in the frozen food aisle
pushing his food cart I went tearing
through the aisles but the phantom of
logic had vanished what was he buying I
asked for tea for the rumor was that the
man ate next to nothing Rorty shook his
head lugubriously and said he'd been to
stew too stunned to notice but I guess
we can assume it was something frozen we
all speculated about what our hero might
be working on
there were strange rumors about a proof
for God's existence which turned out to
be veridical girdle like lighten it so I
should mention after Einstein died and
girdle really mixed with nobody he the
only closest friend was the philosopher
the 17th century philosopher Leibniz he
was quite obsessed with with lightness
and like lightness believed that
everything was a priori everything can
be deduced aproned there's a reason for
everything
therefore the the techniques of
mathematics can can reveal unfilled the
whole of reality Geir don't like live
nuts believe that some version of the
infamous ontological proof for God's
existence was valid this is an argument
that tries to deduce the existence of
God from the right definition of God he
mentioned to at least one colleague at
the Institute the philosopher morten
white that there remained just one step
to be clenched before his new version of
the ontological argument for God's
existence could be published the tone of
our fascination with girdle wasn't
consistently reverential there was even
a decided undercurrent of flippancy we
found it hilarious for example that the
greatest logician since Aristotle
deluded himself into believing that
God's existence could be proved a priori
then he was perhaps contemplating the
day when atheists would be brought round
by a good stiff course and
quantificational logic the stories we
swiped were gratifying in the way that
stories of geniuses acting oddly are
always gratifying we cut our prodigies
down to human size domesticate their
grandeur
- cuddle eNOS with tales of their
quotidian weirdness sometimes we miss
seen what is truly human within these
pro dishes check prodigious talents yet
one more irony that girdles story
suggests thank you
well I wish that I could claim that miss
Leavitt was an ancestress of mine but
she's not however I will say that one
thing I discovered in the course of
researching my book on Alan Turing is
that Alan Turing shirt shared a birthday
with me and also shares a birthday with
Kinsey the great sexologist so conclude
from that whatever you like it makes
sense that I should follow Rebecca and
her wonderful book on girdle by talking
about Turing because there are a lot of
links between Turing's work and girdles
but before I get into that I thought I
would read a little bit from the
beginning of the book this is from a
sort of preface Rory first chapter which
will give you a little bit of a sense of
who Alan Turing was a little bit of
sense of his history in Alexander
McKendrick
1951 Ealing comedy the man in the white
suit Alec Guinness plays Sydney Stratton
a Divya even childlike chemist who
creates a fabric that will never wear
out or get dirty his invention is
heralded as a great step forward until
the owners of the textile mills at which
he was employed along with the members
of the unions representing his fellow
workers realized that it will put them
all out of business soon enough these
perennial antagonists joined forces to
trap Stratton and destroy his fabric
which he is wearing in the form of a
white suit they chase him down corner
him and seemed about to murder him when
at the very last moment the suit begins
to disintegrate failure thus saves
Stratton from the industry he threatens
and saves the industry from obsolescence
it goes without saying that any
parallels drawn between Sydney Stratton
and Alan Turing the English
mathematician the inventor of the modern
computer an architect of the machine
that broke the German Enigma code during
World War two must by necessity be
inexact for one thing such a parallel
demands that we've used Stratton
especially as portrayed by the gay
guinness as at the very least a proto
homosexual figure
while interpreting his hounding as a
metaphor for the more generalized
persecution of homosexuals in England
before the 1967 decriminalization of
acts of gross indecency between adult
men this is obviously a reading of the
man in the white suit that not all of
its admirers will accept and the more
than a few will protest to draw a
parallel between Sidney Stratton and
Alan Turing would also require us to
ignore a crucial difference between the
two scientists well Stratton is hounded
because of his discovery Turing was
hounded in spite of it far from the
failure that his Stratton's white suit
Turing's machines both hypothetical and
real novel not only initiated the age of
the computer but clay played a crucial
role in the Allied victory over Germany
in World War two why then labour the
comparison only because in my view the
man in the white suit has so much to
tell us about the determining conditions
of Alan Turing's short life
homosexuality the scientific imagination
and England in the first half of the
20th century
like Stratton Turing was naive
absent-minded and oblivious to the
forces that threatened him like Stratton
he worked alone like Stratton he wasn't
interested in welding the theoretical to
the practical approaching mathematics
from a perspective that reflected the
industrial ethos of the England in which
he was raised and finally like Stratton
Turing was hounded out of the world by
forces that viewed him as a danger much
as the eponymous hero of e/m foresters
Morris fears that he will be hounded out
of the world if his homosexuality is
discovered dubbed as a security risk
because of his heroic work during World
War two Turing was arrested and tried a
year after the opening of the man in the
white suit and on charges of committing
acts of gross indecency with another man
as an alternative to a prison sentence
he was forced to endure a humiliating
course of estrogen injections intended
to cure him finally in 1954 he committed
suicide by biting into an apple dipped
in cyanide an apparent nod to the
poisoned Apple in
one of his favorite films the Disney
version of Snow White and the Seven
Dwarves and one of which which writers
on Turing in subsequent years have made
much of an interesting coincidence that
Rebecca and I were just discussing is
that seven snow-white in the Seven
Dwarfs was also one of girdle's favorite
films I first learned about touring
really in the context of his role as a
kind of martyr to the laws in England
that criminalized homosexuality and
under which Oscar Wilde was arrested and
under which so many other men suffered
but that is one of only several identity
is one of the things you learn when you
work on the life of a man like Turing is
that different people know him for
different aspects of his work he had he
is known among historians of
homosexuality and lesbian culture gay
and male and lesbian culture in England
as a kind of a martyr he is known among
historians of world war ii as a code
breaker as really the the single
architect or the principal architect of
the program by which the german enigma
code was broken he is known among
mathematicians as computer scientists as
the inventor of what has been come to
has come to be known as the Turing
machine but which he called the a
machine which was in some ways the
theoretical prototype of the modern
computer and he is known among those who
study artificial intelligence as the
developer of the Turing test although
that was not his name for it which is a
test that in a sense tries to establish
whether a machine can be distinguished
from a human being all of these
discoveries and all of this work took
place over the course of a life that was
comparatively short and that was cut off
by his suicide I thought I would talk a
little bit today about the discovery of
the Turing machine and also about the
Turing test and this does relate to
girdle's work when
approved the incompleteness and the
inconsistency of first-order
mathematical systems and and I hope that
the mathematicians in the audience will
forgive me if my language is a little
bit imprecise he was responding to two
of three proofs that the great German
mathematician David Hilbert had called
for in his effort to in a sense
stabilize the mathematical landscape
Hilbert was very interested in the
fundamental underpinnings of mathematics
he wanted the the the foundations of
mathematics and when he called for
proofs of the consistency and
completeness of mathematics I think he
took it for granted that the proofs
would be positive in fact girdle's
proofs showed that mathematics was
incomplete and inconsistent but there
was a third point that that Hilbert was
interested and that had to do with the
idea of whether mathematics was
decidable and the way that he phrased
the question was this he said does there
exist an algorithm that decides the
validity of any given first order
formula what he was essentially asking
was whether or not there was what he was
asking for a proof and as Rebecca
pointed out so eloquently mathematicians
are in the business of proof not dis
proof is easy proof is difficult
proof is challenging and it's in proof
that the aesthetics of mathematics
really come into play is there a proof
could it could have proof be given to
show that any formula was either
provable or unprovable decidable or
undecidable and this was known as the
insight ohms problem or the decision
problem
and when Turing began his career at
Cambridge in the 1930s as a pure
mathematician and he was taking a course
from Max Newman who was a famous avatar
of the field of topology and and newman
mentioned the as-yet unproven uncha
domes problem in a lecture and when
Hilbert's language was he'll were
referred to the idea of a definite
for determining the decidability of a
mathematical formula Newman translated
this into the idea of a mechanical
process
this was Newman's term and Turing who
was very very literal-minded heard the
word mechanical and he immediately
started thinking of machines now I was
very very glad to hear Allen earlier
mentioning the fact that that the word
computer originally referred to the
people mostly women who did computations
and that was very much the context in
England as well as in America and miss
Leavitt my nan ancestress was was one of
these computers Turing was really the
first person who took the idea of a
computer as a person and turned it into
the idea of the computer as a machine
essentially what he wanted to prove was
that the decidability problem was
insoluble he wanted to prove and this
would be the third step in in basically
demolishing Hilbert's very idealistic
program he wanted to prove that there
was no definite method that there was no
mechanical process by which the
decidability of a given formula could be
proven and when he heard that word
mechanical he immediately started
thinking of machines and so he came up
with this idea of a machine a very very
simple machine that would correspond to
a given algorithm and algorithm being a
method for solving a problem and what do
you that envisioned was was sort of a
small machine with an endless tape
running through it and on the tape the
machine could could print two symbols of
imprinted could print a one or could
print a zero and it could move the tapes
of the left it could move the tape to
the right the tape could stay still and
he started off with with some very very
basic simple machines that would to
perform algorithms as simple as adding
two and two and getting four and and his
first step in the proof was to show that
there that these machines could exist
then for every algorithm there could be
a Turing machine
even for the most complicated algorithms
even for such complicated Albury
algorithms as the Bessel functions and
other very very sophisticated algorithms
he proved that there was a corresponding
machine a machine that with only these
few capabilities the ability to move the
tape one direction or another the
ability to print a one the ability to
print a zero these machines could
perform these algorithms and either
generate a sequence of answers every
answer to the given algorithm say the
algorithm is is 1 plus x equals y they
would go through every single answer or
alternately they would simply provide
the answer and then stop he then
expanded this idea to the idea of a
universal machine and the idea was if
there was a machine corresponding to
every algorithm and you could actually
number these machines and list them
could there be such a thing as a
universal machine that could in effect
interpret the instructions that would be
given to each individual machine and
thereby having interpreted the
instructions perform the function of
that machine and then having developed
the idea of the universal machine he
used this machine this concept of the
machine to show that the decision
problem was insoluble and the
mathematics in addition to being
inconsistent and incomplete
was also undecidable it seems to us now
like a pretty revolutionary discovery
but at the time it was pretty much
ignored and that was in part because in
those days mathematical logic was not in
the best owner in the mathematical
community but it was also because Turing
had been beaten to the punch he'd been
beaten to the punch by a Princeton
mathematician named Alonzo Church who
had come to the same conclusion but come
to it in what I think we would all say
now is a much less interesting way
Turing I don't think realized the
implications of what he'd done he had
invented this hypothetical machine with
no intention of ever building it how
after all could you build a machine that
relied on an endless tape we don't there
aren't really endless tapes in the world
it was it was part of a proof but he had
come across
revolutionary idea which was that there
could be a machine that could imitate
the function of other machines and
thereby be truly universal and this was
really the prototype of the modern
computer and Turing had come up with it
really without realizing it as he
continued on in his career he became
increasingly interested in the idea of
making the hypothetical Turing machine
into a real machine and as he moved
forward in this he encountered a number
of roadblocks one of the roadblocks was
the second world war in which he was
recruited to be part of the code
breaking effort at Bletchley Park and
this was both a positive and a negative
it was a negative because it took him
away from it for a number of years from
what was his principle interest in his
principal work but it was a positive in
that it gave him some hands-on
experience in machine building he
contributed he really provided the
theoretical underpinnings for the
building of a machine called bomb Bo MBE
which was the machine through the use of
which the the German Enigma code was
broken his idea was that if the code was
generated by one machine it would take
another machine to break it after World
War two he found himself confronted with
well he'd been he'd been more or less he
hadn't exactly been beaten to the punch
but there already were computers in
existence in America principally a
computer called the ante ack that that
were built on very different on a very
different philosophical foundation than
his own this was these were computers
that required what he called screwdriver
interference they had to be if you
wanted to change what the computer did
you had to go in with a screwdriver and
effectively rebuild it whereas here his
idea was a simple even minimalist
machine that could in a sense imitate
any other machine and in this regard he
was really coming up with very early a
very early prototype of the modern idea
of hardware and software so he was ahead
of his time in many many ways and at the
same time he was constantly being beaten
too
the punch and and and losing out on
opportunities the other problem that he
had was he would be interested in
something up to a point and then once
his idea started to be realized he he
would become distracted and become
interested in something else and one of
the the in the later period of his life
he became very interested in the idea of
artificial intelligence and he came up
with the idea of the Turing test or what
he the imitation game he called it and
the way the imitation game worked was
essentially you have in one room a human
being and in the other room a computer
and you ask them questions and the idea
is on the basis of their answers can you
deduce which is the human being and
which is the computer especially if the
computer has been trained to behave in
much the same way as a human being his
argument was that this would be a proof
that computers could be said to think
that they could be said to exhibit
intelligence which was a very
frightening idea at that time
principally because there was a lot of
fear of the idea that if computers could
actually think they could take over the
world and kill us all and it would be a
sort of a version of Samuel Butler's
novel erawan and all hell would break
loose and Turing was really convinced of
this idea and yet behind the idea there
was a whole agenda or a set of agenda
that had to do with his own experience
as a homosexual man at least I would
argue so and a lot of a lot has been
written about this a lot of arguing back
and forth but I just want to give you a
couple of quotes from the famous paper
in which Turing proposed the idea of the
Turing test to give you a sense of how
he conceived he was increasingly
conceiving of computers as thinking
sentient beings and also of the ways in
which a lot of his own anxieties and
concerns about his own homosexuality
we're starting to reveal themselves
through his writing and in a sense the
way in which I would argue his later
work especially his later papers encoded
a sort of a plea for
and justice and equality towards all
oppressed populations including both
human and machine the oppressed
population of machines and the oppressed
population of gay men and women this is
this is a passage in which he's he's
he's basically predicting the arguments
that will be used against the idea of a
machine being able to think and one of
these arguments he calls argue well
there's a whole category of arguments
that he calls arguments from various
disabilities which he defines as taking
the form quote I grant that you can make
machines do all the things you have
mentioned but you will never be able to
make one do X and the event offers a
rather tongue-in-cheek selection of the
various things that you will never be
able to make a machine do be kind
resourceful beautiful friendly have
initiative have a sense of humor tell
right from wrong make mistakes fall in
love enjoy strawberries and cream make
someone fall in love with it learn from
experience use words properly be the
subject of its own thought have as much
diversity of behavior as a man do
something really new and I should add
here that that that another way in which
Turing's argument I think encodes an
argument for a toleration of gay men and
lesbians is that for him behavior is
identity if a computer can persuade you
that it's whom human than it is human ok
as Turing notes no support is usually
offered for these statements most of
which are founded on principles of
scientific induction the works and
customs of mankind do not seem to be
very suitable material to which to apply
scientific induction a very large part
of space time must be investigated if
reliable results are be obtained or to
be obtained otherwise we may as most
English children do decide that
everybody speaks English and that it is
silly to learn French Turing then goes
on and and I'll just read a little bit
more and then I'll stop so we can take
some questions
I think we're um are we out of time I
can't I can't finish my arguments okay
well thank you very much
I'm sorry we didn't have time for
questions I had my own questions I'm
sorry I had to interrupt David I was
given a note
welcome to Dave Barry thank you so much
for attending
might be published all ahead is good
the scooter
stunned to realize and I had no idea